so part two this is the integration and
it gave you guys some trouble so let me
try and explain there are at least two
things in my mind or two reasons why um
that this integration and this
particular result would give you some
grief so let me start off by
writing out the equation of motion
because to review in part two the
question they literally said
by integrating the equation of motion
this is this has to be our starting
point right so i've got mg minus kv
squared
on the right hand side now at this point
we can begin like the first step is a
pretty autopilot sort of step right i
want to separate out my variables and
prepare for the integration process it's
after that that the work and the
thinking really begins so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to separate out my my
v's and my t's as best as i can
i've got the dv on the left hand side
there already and that's going to stay
put but you can see my v terms are over
here on the right hand side so i'm just
going to divide through
by that mg
minus kb squared like so
and often we sort of pull this trick
where we say oh look that constant
that constant coefficient out there
let's let's take it over to the right
hand side and integrate it with t
because that's where that's going to end
up like so however in this case the
question gives me a clue that that's not
really worthwhile right because have a
look when you can see up here on the
left hand side i'm just going to land on
a t equals whatever equation right so
therefore getting that dt isolated
completely on that right hand side to in
sort of as i head towards integration
makes sense because i don't i'm not
going to want anything with that t
in the end so i might as well not put
anything there
on the way so therefore that m which is
here on the left hand side to begin with
i'm just going to leave it there on the
left hand side and it stays put
okay now at this point like i said we're
now preparing for integration and
there's a couple of things you want to
keep in mind okay the first one is
at this point it's a fairly normal
instinctive thing to just do the
integration and just say yeah i'm just
going to whack on i'll use this color
here i'm just going to whack on these
integral signs and then off i go and
eventually i'm going to have a constant
integration to have to deal with and
i'll use initial conditions in some way
to um to evaluate that right and that's
fine in theory there's no problem with
that approach
however i'm going to make a case for why
it actually might be useful for us to
actually
treat this as a definite integral we've
seen this a little bit in the past but
it's kind of a technique we often don't
go to we tend to use this as an
indefinite integral and then deal with
the constant later my suggestion for why
this is useful is when you have a look
at the result that's been required to
prove
there's this amazing symmetry there
right and you can see how often vt the
terminal velocity appears in here so i'm
going to have to do a substitution for
that but you've also got this v naught
that appears in here and it's just such
a symmetrical result i kind of want to
take advantage of that symmetry in my
integration process and do that sooner
rather than later the sooner you can
make things symmetrical the easier they
are to deal with
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
integrate as you maybe remember from
before but it's been a while since i've
been in mechanics land i'm going to
integrate from an initial condition up
to some arbitrary time right so an
arbitrary time is literally just you
know t
whatever time you like when you have
some arbitrary time um you will have
some arbitrary velocity right so this t
and this v are going to be variables but
then when you think about the initial
condition this is when um jack and jill
they first pull their parachute so
that's defined if you go back to the
questions initial paragraph as time 0
and their initial velocity
it's not the initial one as they jump
out of the plane that's just zero right
they're vertically stationary because
they're still on the plane but once they
hit their shoot that's defined as v
zero right so you can see i've kind of
placed all of these um all of these
upper and lower bounds quite
thoughtfully based on where i'm going to
be headed okay now i said um
that i need to think carefully about
this result i'm required to prove and
this is probably where the obstacles
were for some of you i've dealt with the
fact that these v0s appear they're going
to come into my definite integral once i
evaluate the upper and lower bounds but
there's no vts right um i don't have i
haven't written anything here about vt
because i don't really want to put like
infinity and then a vt here because
infinity is not actually a number that i
can just substitute in right it's a
limiting process
so where these vt is going to appear and
i think the clue for you is by noticing
what's here on the left-hand side and
what isn't in the result that's required
to prove did you notice it
do you realize there's no reference to
the mass of jack or jill
nor is there a reference to k this
constant of proportionality which
sometimes we call the drag coefficient
right no m's no k's
suddenly it's all just oops it is it's
all just vts right see these guys so
this is your clue for how we're going to
have to use part one
part one tells us vt in terms of m's and
g's and k's the g is going to stay put
you can see one right there but the m's
and k's we are going to need to get rid
of and we're going to do substitution in
terms of vt okay
so that was a lot of thinking before we
did any writing when we did put these
integral signs on but we're now ready to
go okay
i'm going to pull just a little quick
move here which is to put my my t terms
on the left hand side because that's
where they're going to end up my result
that i'm required to prove is a t equals
etc so i'm going to go here's the uh
upper bound and here's the lower bound
so there's the whole
original right hand side completely
integrated what do i get on the other
side with all my my m's and v's and that
kind of thing okay
what i'm going to do is a couple of
steps before i actually perform the
integration here right
i'm going to have this m which is a
constant coefficient out the front and
then i've got my integral from v naught
to v of 1
over
mg minus kv squared okay now just pause
on this for a moment and think about how
how can you deal with this right what is
going to be a tool that you can use
we've dealt with quadratic denominators
before um what is going to be the most
helpful way to get out of this and again
if if it's not immediately apparent to
you the question gives you some clues
right that result that's required to
prove it's a log right i mean you have
to see through all this other premium
stuff in there but it's log of some
stuff and then when you notice in here
you've got this product and this
denominator here a product in the
numerator and a product in the
denominator i should say
if you know your log laws well one of
the things you can see is what this will
come from is
a series of log terms some of which are
added and some of which are subtracted
right because when you add and subtract
log terms that becomes multiplication
and division inside of the log right so
that should be the clue to you that well
how what what's going to give you a
bunch of different log terms that you
can separately um will come out of the
integration and you can separately put
together and the answer is this is going
to be a bunch of partial fractions do
you see that um you're not i mean you
could try and complete the square down
here you could try and treat this is
like oh is this one of these like
inverse trig
integrals because i've got a quadratic
in the denominator and the answer is
that log term in the result you're
required to prove
should signal to you that i'm going to
need to separate this out into a pair of
different fractions that will then
become logs
excuse me after i integrate okay so
like i said there's a fair bit of
question here and i think this is
probably why some of you had trouble
with this integral
just before i get there to make this
even clearer right you can see i've got
these m's and g's flying around which i
still haven't um sorry m's and k's
flying around that i haven't gotten rid
of right so how do i deal with this well
what i'm going to do
is noticing if i go back up here right
can you see this line
i'm going to highlight it like so this
line right here
i can use this anytime i can see m's and
k's i can use that to get rid of
vt squared right or i use that to put in
vt squared i should say so a couple of
ways i can say that is well let's first
call this equation one
you can see if i just have an m and a k
by itself what that tells me is that m
over k
is going to be vt squared
all divided by g can you see i just
divided both sides by g on that
on that equation so therefore i'm going
to call this equation here 1 a and you
can use both 1 and 1 a to do a
substitution on this integral so that
you get the vt's appearing that you're
supposed to get in your record
result that you're required to prove
okay
let's divide through by k for example
because you can see i've got this m on k
hanging out the front which i can do a
substitution of but if i put that m on k
out the front what's that going to leave
me with on the inside well i'll just
leave that numerator alone
you can see the k is going to come out
of here just fine so that will leave me
with a minus v squared but then here
it's going to become mg on k usually we
try and avoid fractions inside fractions
but this one's going to work for us
because i know what mg on k is equal to
from equation one right so this one here
is going to be a high like that that's
going to be equation one that i'll use
to substitute and this one will equation
one a if i just sort of scroll up
hopefully you can see them both there
right so there's the m1k there's the mg
on k which i can which i can do here
so let's do the substitution and there
will be no more m's and k's to worry
about right what do i get out the front
this is the v t squared on g that i was
mentioning and then inside i'm going to
have i've still got these boundaries
here which i haven't dealt with yet i've
got one on
that's v t
squared and then i've got a minus v
squared over there okay now maybe this
is starting to shape up for you because
when you said well when i said partial
fractions you might have said partial
fractions of what and now you can see
this difference of squares appearing on
the denominator so you can actually deal
with that as well each of your factors
will become a separate denominator right
so just to make that a bit clearer you
can see
i'm going to
write the same constant coefficient at
the front but i'll write that
factorization just to make it a little
clearer what i'm doing so here come the
difference of squares vt minus v
and vt plus v